- The way the press treated us
and what was acceptable,
whether it's, you know,
asking me my measurements
on nationwide television,
asking me to stand up,
Barbara Walters did that,
and compared herself to me.
And just this sort of,
the approach that they had
in asking me questions
as a 12-year-old,
was really just unconscionable.
And, to see that-
- It like stirs rage.
- [Brooke] It does.
- Yeah.
- It does.
I mean, as a mom too,
- Mm-hm.
- it just breaks my heart
to see that little girl.
But, you know, I went to regular schools,
I went to college.
I always had this knowledge that,
if I don't have something
that's gonna keep me grounded,
I'm gonna get eaten up
by this business.
- Yeah.
- I am going to just get lost in it
and it's gonna, it's
going to obliterate me.
And then what will I have?
And I knew I needed something grounding.
I knew I needed a family.
- Maybe that's what saved you
is stepping outside of that
- Absolutely.
- and doing something, more normal,
you know.
- And just seeing another,
world and not,
and being a kid,
you know, the having
that sort of experience.
And then I also wanted to win.
- Yeah.
- Do you know what I mean?
I wanted to prove to other people
but to myself,
that you can't,
I'm right here
and I have grown
- Yeah.
- into this person
and I'm like a Weeble,
you're not gonna knock me over.
- Yeah.
- You know?
- I'm gonna come right back.
So.
(audience applauds)